bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys what's up bang bang
we're in a studio we'll have more on
that later today i've got a special
guest for you
my friend mike probably one of my best
friends we've got all kinds of crazy
stories that we are not going to talk
about on the podcast today
uh but we used to live together in san
francisco along with a bunch of other
people
who we will not bring on the podcast
because they're too outrageous
uh what's up man how you doing i'm doing
great you were the first person in this
room
it's nice got a good setup here yeah
mike sat down and he looked around and
it was one of those looks of like uh
oh [ __ ] this is real this is big time
all right uh let's start i actually have
notes i'm gonna be really serious for
like two episodes and then i'll go back
to being myself
um let's just talk about your background
first uh we met at facebook but before
your facebook what did you do
uh before facebook i was a consultant so
spent time building financial systems
for big fortune 100 businesses
ge tag crafts i'm a property group so
right at the start of my career just
thrown into the deep end building
financial systems
first day on the job they dropped a
300-page user manual on my desk they
said
oracle hyperion strategic finance you
got two weeks go figure it out
so it was pretty intense but i think for
me i felt really fortunate i was just
working with finance executives learning
the ropes
and building the financial systems you
get the chance to build their financial
models so you understand
every single driver all the different
lovers how the business model works
uh and so being able to work across a
bunch of different industries seeing a
bunch of different processes
helped me early on in my career build
these mental maps of like
okay this is how corporate finance is
done this is how
when you watch cnbc and you get the
earnings and it's like
okay we are here's our earnings
projections here's our guidance
here's how all this is done here's all
this is made that accuracy becomes so
important
uh so yeah really fortunate to start off
my career building those types of
systems
i did a project with facebook a couple a
few weeks into it project was going
really well
uh the vp of enterprise engineering took
me on the long walk
in the middle in the middle of facebook
uh and started recruiting me
uh and you know i was you know at the
time living in chicago
uh had a condo like life was kind of set
like was really kind of you know
had good friends and like my family was
there uh
gave me an offer to join facebook and
you know he was like exploding offer you
got two weeks this was like right around
christmas
uh ended up accepting the offer new
year's eve moved out of my place
new year's day i was in san francisco uh
and i think we stumbled into each other
like a couple weeks once you go on the
walk
they got you like for those that don't
know at facebook if you go on the walk
they have you because there's a long
walk
look how great this place is and then
they're like oh by the way here's an
offer uh
you should take this and then you take
it that's how they get you there yeah uh
all right before we get into facebook uh
because i feel like that's like a very
specific
uh situation yeah these financial
systems i think most people don't
understand like
how intricate and complex they are so
you mentioned um
like projecting earnings literally down
to the
cent right or to the dollar um and
is it fair to say that like all this is
it's just people are taking all the
inputs
they're then saying all right we're
gonna run it through our historicals
plus whatever we think are the new
inputs
and then literally it gives us an output
for this system
and that's how we're gonna like
literally manage the business so on a
day-to-day basis we can tell are we a
header below uh the projections where we
believe we're going to be
and like really that's like kind of what
is the heartbeat of the business to some
degree right
absolutely i mean at the end of the day
it's all about you know a business is
about
you know taking in cash to generate more
cash and driving those returns uh
and what's interesting you mentioned
kind of like the day-to-day you know and
i think
the problem with current state financial
systems is you don't have that
day-to-day
visibility and i think people spend a
lot of times building these financial
plans
and the way that typically works is the
finance team will work with board of
directors executive management team
and they'd say okay here's roughly what
we think the business should look like
very top-down exercise
planning very strategically around okay
here's the initiative that we want to do
here's the market share that we want to
take
here's the growth profile that we think
we need to have
and then that always kind of cascades
down to the different department loads
and the business leaders
and so then there's this really big
exercise to say okay
here's rough shape of what the business
should look like guidance then every
single functional head in a business vp
of product vp of engineering
sales marketing every single group kind
of has their guidance and their targets
then they go operationalize that and
they say okay
what projects do we want to do who do we
need to hire what pieces of software
that we need to buy
and they substantiate those targets with
what people describe as a bottoms up
build and so this is like
bottoms up everybody in the business
what are they actually going to
to do to execute on those plans make
sure that they can hit their goals
hit those targets and so there's a lot
of kind of just
information that cascades down and then
it needs to cascade up
and that's a long process like it takes
a really long time to do those plans i
mean
people typically you know start that
process maybe q3 where they start
thinking about this stuff for the for
the following year
and then almost all of q4 sometimes for
some of these businesses is consumed
with this planning exercise
and then what my biggest insight was is
being a part of that at so many
different businesses being part of
facebook leading the finance team at
zenefits building these financial plans
is
you spend all this time creating those
plans and immediately as you say okay
this plan is done it's set it just
collects dust you know and it just sits
there then people actually go
off and execute you know like okay we've
set our annual plan
literally two or three weeks later you
know your marketer is like uh
actually i'm gonna double down on this
project punt on this project instead of
a full-time hire i'm gonna hire a
contractor you know and they make all
these different changes
uh and that is really tough to capture
from a finance team who spent all this
time building this
model it's just a it's just a model uh
and so that's kind of what brings us to
trace where i've like i've learned these
insights solve this problem
and i think finance it needs to be more
real-time it needs to have that
day-to-day visibility
what are the actual decisions that
people are making and how does that
impact our financial results and that's
exactly what you know so we founded
trace a few years ago
to solve that problem where we help
people make those day-to-day decisions
they can purchase they can hire
they manage their projects uh and then
we help give them real-time visibility
okay how does that actually impact our
plan
and the way that takes effect on our
product is you get you know a top-down
target
and then people can execute and then you
can make sure that you set that guidance
you told wall street like what you're
gonna do let's make sure that as we're
executing we have that day-to-day
visibility
uh into into uh yeah how we're gonna how
we're gonna do what we're gonna do
the other way to do it the old way is
like set our financial plan
everything happens we add everything up
in the accounting system
and then we hope that it it matches and
then we try to do like an analysis and
understand that variance
it almost feels like there's a uh a
complete disjoint between the finance
team
and then like the rest of the teams
right and the rest of the teams
they're getting told by the finance team
hey your budget is to hire three people
uh and we need you know ten million
dollars of revenue from you this year
and then the team's like okay cool and
then they go and they kind of do
whatever they want and they hope that
they come back
with the numbers and you know i'm over
generalizing but like to some degree the
finance team doesn't really know until
they come back whether it's on a weekly
monthly or quarterly basis
what those financial performance numbers
look like and so it's almost like this
infrequent uh non-real-time
understanding of the business
right and that's where you get some of
the quarterly projections and numbers
and stuff like that
so it sounds like the solution here is
just make it as
dynamic as possible shorten the feedback
loops and make it more real-time right
that's essentially what you guys are
ultimately trying to do
absolutely absolutely all right so let's
talk about facebook uh
i'm gonna tell a quick story to tell you
how how good a friends mike and i
are some of our old colleagues may
listen to this and just laugh uh
i used to ping mike on uh facebook and
uh and messenger which the company uses
and i'd be like hey man uh are you busy
and it'd be like noon he'd be like
nah i got like some free time this
afternoon i'm like all right and then we
would put
a meeting invite on our calendars
and for like you know 30 45 maybe an
hour
and then we'd go to the gym
[Laughter]
for the same time yeah and we'd go to
the gym and we'd work out and it would
just be like meeting with mike
and literally we'd go to the gym we
would just talk about we usually would
actually talk about like business
related stuff
but that was our like escape is if we
had a slow day we'd go do it so we're
we're pretty good friends and we've been
doing uh stuff together for a long time
yeah we used to also wake up 4 30 a.m
take that first shuttle
in no traffic get the first ones in the
office
people uh i laughed the whole miami
thing it's like
man in san francisco uh back in
probably 2010 12 13 14 like nobody cared
about the tech industry
and then all of a sudden they had like
facebook and google and linkedin and all
these buses going through their city and
they were like hey who are these people
like not cool and so i think that like
that's the big
thing that miami's got to be careful of
is that like right now nobody cares
about the tech people
but if you go and you do crazy stuff
then they're probably going to care a
lot
yeah yeah i actually always give you
credit for that because when i was
living in chicago
i was a consultant big fortune 100
businesses you know and i used to watch
cnbc i really cared about the markets
and like
you know and then i moved to san
francisco and you know facebook was a
publicly traded company at the time
but started getting immersed in the
world of startups you know and i think
being friends with you opened my eyes
you were already a successful
entrepreneur you sold a company in the
past
and i think our relationship and our
friendship is really what opened my eyes
to like actually digging deep and i
you can probably even remember back in
the days i was like working on all sorts
of side projects
i was like you were you introduced me to
like the first engineer i've ever worked
with you know i was tinkering on
on all sorts of things and it's amazing
you can you know fast forward like you
know five years later it's actually
took the plunge you know left the job
went all in on starting something
i i used to enjoy on friday nights mike
and i before we'd go out we would get
drunk and then we'd argue over all kinds
of dumb stuff like hey man we think
about this company like it's trash you'd
be like i think it's going to be great
and you win some of you lose some until
we always laugh about it
uh what was your biggest takeaway from
working at facebook like what do you
think was the thing that
uh from working in and maybe describe a
little bit about like the role that you
had inside the finance team
and like what was the biggest learning
uh that's a good question
um i often think if i can go back to
facebook
what i would do differently sometimes
that's a question i always ask myself
um and i would have like networked
aggressively and i think when you're
inside of those businesses and you have
a chance to work with so many smart
people so many dynamic people
knowing that i would have been an
entrepreneur i wish i would have just
met as many people as possible
instead of just going to the gym with
you every single day
it's like it's an amazing place to go
spend time and just learn the ropes and
really network you know because i think
you realize as you're building your
companies like
being able to recruit great designers
and great engineers like
all that matters so much but to your
question like what did i learn
the most you know i think what i learned
was i wasn't a
good fit for a big company to be
completely honest uh
i think when i was at facebook you know
i was responsible for building
financial systems fpa systems kind of
the top-down more strategic models
we were building five and ten-year
models to do you know data center
planning and like really long-term
strategic planning
and i think what i felt i needed was
like i saw what those before
before me at facebook had built and i
was like i want to go build
you know and i think that was probably
the biggest learning for me i always
tell people yeah i was like
i was at facebook for five quarters and
people laughed like you're such a
finance guy you think about things in
terms of quarters you know
uh and it was enough cycles for me to
learn that like actually i want to go
build you know and so that's where
i started looking earlier stage not
founding but you know going to like
series c series d whereas kind of like
at that stage where you need to build a
lot of that early infrastructure
um so that was yeah that was definitely
my biggest my biggest learning all right
and then
at zenifitz uh i always joke that you
are my one friend who went from
i got a new job to i'm running the place
basically on the finance side
at zenith and it happened in like a year
i think or maybe a year and a half or
whatever
um what did you start at and then how
did you get to
well you're the vp of finance i think
right you get vp and kind of talk
through just like the building process
and like what systems you guys had to
build
and like what you learned there yeah i
came in at ic ic level
uh i think at the time there was really
not a team being built yet
um i see for those that are listening as
individual contributors individual
contributors yeah and i think the
the there was really no foundation i
think you know our kind of
uh directive was go build up the finance
go find it build the finance
infrastructure you know and get
this place ready to go public at some
point uh we need
kind of to grow i think at that point we
were about 500 employees when i joined
by the end of that that first year we
were 1800 employees so it was like
insane growth
i joined just before we closed the big
500 million series c financing
uh and so that was fun to be a part of i
didn't lead the financing but i was able
to participate help build the models
help
prepare the presentations um and i think
you know early on i brought just
discipline to how we built our models
how we presented
how things were organized um i think you
know david sacks who
was ceo at the time joked that like my
formatting on the models probably
increased our valuation by like a
billion dollars
just the cleanliness aspect of it uh and
that discipline extended into as we
started to build so
i like i said i was so fortunate in my
early days my
the first few years of my career to you
know work with those big fortune 100
businesses
understand organizationally how were
they set up
how what are their processes what
technologies do they use
and so that i learned the playbook and i
think when i joined zenefits
i quickly implemented that playbook to
say
here's what the modeling environment
should look like here's what our team
structure should look like here's the
portfolio of services that we need to
provide to our business partner here's
kind of how all this should
should orchestrate and i think once you
kind of lay down that foundation
uh it really establishes yourself as a
leader on the team
and so i think that got me a promotion
to director there was a lot of
change happening at zenfit benefits grew
way too fast
we ran into some compliance issues and
then we had some tough decisions to to
make
um and i think one thing that you know
about me is you know i think
um always always okay to speak my mind
you know and i think when times get
tough i think you know having somebody
who
um you know is willing to make tough
decisions that are the right decisions
for the business becomes really
important
uh and i think that kind of what earned
me my seat to kind of take over
take over more of the finance function
and to participate in board meetings
and to help drive some of those
decisions around restructuring
uh which are really tough things to do
but at that point i mean
it's it saved the business for sure yeah
it feels like that's one of the stories
of silicon valley of like
you get all of the experiences wrapped
up in 12 to 18 months right like
hey it's a rocket ship hey things are
now kind of unsteady
uh we've got the compliance or kind of
regulatory issues we've got
a change of leadership like all these
different things that we've got to
restructure the business
like you really get a lot of experience
very very quickly
uh which if you're going there to learn
is like actually the ideal kind of
uh you know path that the company goes
through um
what was the biggest thing you took away
like when it's all said and done you
walk away right you go
start a business but like when you think
back like what's the thing you learned
uh i mean i think it's business
fundamentals matter you know and
and it's yeah shocking shocking alert
alert
2021 breaking news yeah and it's and
it's crazy right because you look at
some business where the unit economics
are upside
unit economics are upside down and
investors are still piling cash into
these businesses and the playbook has
worked in some instances where it's like
even though the unit economics are
upside down and unit economics being
looking at for what's the unit of value
that you know delivers you know uh
future value for this business and so
a lot of software businesses it's like a
license or a seat
or a user you know or for uber it might
be a writer or something along those
lines
and so for every dollar that we earn
from you know
that unit are we able to get three
dollars in the future and a lot of times
these businesses are like actually
we're gonna pay a dollar right now to
get 80 cents in the future because
we're gonna go win market share and
expect that that dollar will be worth
three dollars yeah we'll build future
products or whatever
exactly and that 80 cents will then grow
to 120 153
yeah and you have to be really really
careful about where you apply apply
those principles
uh and i think you know zenifits at one
point had
um really strong unit economics in
certain
in certain areas in terms of its ability
to um
so zenfit's provided free hr software
and then monetize as an insurance broker
really disruptive model you know i think
people everybody needs hr software as
soon as you start a business you need hr
hr software and to get that software for
free and then also have just you know
somebody be your insurance broker
and that and you know and you can
provide that free software in exchange
and that
you know broker commission that you're
able to get it's really valuable you
know i gotta i gotta admit something
real quick
uh i wanted to test it out one time so i
went in and i put like uh you know name
whatever
and i got like three clicks in the
funnel and i was like i don't got time
for this like i'll come back and check
it out alex from zenifitz is still
emailing me
like i don't know who alex from benefits
is i don't even know he's a real person
but still
emailing me i've unsubscribed i've
blocked et cetera but i'm still getting
emails so zenifitz
definitely knew what they were doing
they were awesome they were
relentlessly
uh when you decided to leave did you
know you want to go start a company
uh i did i did yeah and so i yeah when i
decided to leave it was
on the on the on the on the plan to go
start a company up
all right why trace and what what the
hell do you guys do i think people see
it they're like wow these guys have like
great investors and like
they're smart but like what is finance
systems yeah
yeah well trace is the first service
desk for finance teams
all right what does that mean we help
people in a business purchase hire and
manage their projects
those are really the fundamental
building blocks of any operating plan
it's what people do to you know deploy
and invest
their their resources and their and
their capital and most software
businesses
i mean 60 to 70 percent of their spend
is on is on hiring and head count
and then they purchase things like
software uh you have professional
services and contractors
trace facilitates all of that work uh
and so it gives people
a mechanism to go you know get those
things done
um and then it gives the finance team
visibility into what these people
are doing uh and so the old world of
this process
is like you know you collect a request
and you like stamp it for approved and
like those people
get these those things done what we do
is we collect this great information we
automatically give finance teams
forecast so going back to that you know
example that we said we need to give
people real time visibility
uh into into how their you know business
is going to perform into the future
we give that to people automatically and
so this is kind of like a paradigm shift
i think people always think about these
old traditional financial models
we're kind of flipping on his head and
saying you know you need to collaborate
with your business to collect these
requests
let's maximize the use of these requests
and understand what what's committed you
know what is my committed spend what's
my committed forecast what's pending
approval
what's been approved and how does that
impact my business
and that's powerful information set like
a finance teams to accurately you know
manage the business uh one of my friends
he's a he's a head of finance at like
you know
one of the top sas companies he says it
best and he's a big fan of basketball
he's like the current finance tool set
is like a coach
you know coaching a game and not being
able to make any adjustments until the
game is over
you know he's like coaches have to be
able to make adjustments in real time
and the way to do that is to collaborate
with the business
understand the decisions that they're
making understanding how those decisions
will impact
the broader financial system financial
plan and then make adjustments and tweak
and that's what trace allows people to
do all right before we keep going
how do people go buy the software
because if you run a business of what
size what's the ideal
customer size i think once you have
around 100 or 150 employees you
typically
start to have just enough distribution
enough people across the business where
it starts to make
starts to make sense you have a finance
team in place
we're still trying to figure out what
the upper bound is we just closed our
first enterprise deal
nice nice sales yeah it was a 1500
person uh business they're gonna be 2000
employees by the end of the year
uh and so our you know our goal approach
is like let's focus on growth stage
businesses now before they have all this
infrastructure
so like 100 to 1500. 100 to 1500 is a
good kind of all right
tracehq.com traceygo by the way
for those that don't know if you talk to
the sales team
mike's brother matt he runs the sales
team right he's a sales team
all right uh he's an absolute animal
he he will explain to you why uh you're
an idiot if you haven't been using the
software
absolutely um what's it like starting a
company with your brother
uh i mean it's amazing it's amazing and
it's hard
at the same time i mean i i can't lie
and say it's been like
you know perfect at every single step of
the road i think the ceo vp of sales was
always an interesting relationship
as is and then you know me and matt i
mean we are
i've got i've got four brothers you've
got one and we're all very similar
very similar yeah him and i are like so
competitive but at the same time we have
the same goal we want the same things
uh it's honestly been one of the most
rewarding things in my life
me and matt i mean we have a really
special relationship as you know
um he's my brother he's my best friend
but i i love him like like a father
you know and i want him to do well i
always want him to succeed
and so it's yeah i think him and i being
able to work towards the same thing it's
it's incredible when i'm working
weekends working nights i jump into
slack it's like
you know whose little bubble do i see
there it's like it's mats you know it's
like the guy is just he's just getting
after it you know
there's been tensions there's been hard
times you know and i think
i think there's like little brother big
brother things that happen you know and
we always manage through those those
things
but isn't it fair to say that uh
actually you would have tension with
like any executive team right just
naturally as you build a business and
it's easier to resolve with your brother
because you can just be honest
we can be honest yeah but i think when
there's other executives there's a level
of professionalism for sure you know
and like him and i we keep it
professional like all the time but i
think we also
we also like let you know things come
out as well like and have a little bit
more
heated and heartfelt debates you know
yeah and i think it's a superpower you
know because
when you when you have that trust with
somebody and you know that at the end of
the day
they at the end of the day nothing else
matters you can make zero dollars like
they just want you to be successful and
that's the root of the relationship and
it's like that family bond
you can get through anything you know um
but but you can
like and the only reason i know this is
because i do with my brothers like yeah
you're professional whatever and then
there's one moment you're just like dude
i will whoop your
ass right and the younger brothers say
the older brother older brother say the
younger brother whatever like that
eventually comes out and everyone's like
all right chilling like you wanna go get
some food
right and then like and it's perfectly
fine you pretend like it never happened
and it's weird to other people
right but i think to like people who
have brothers specifically right
it's just like that's like a natural
thing yeah and so it's uh
it's unique uh and as i've worked more
with my brothers like
you realize like you're like exactly
you're saying like yeah i want them to
be successful
but like hey man don't forget like you
know you're the little brother
[Laughter]
it's all my little brothers and matt you
know yeah yeah and matt's like yeah i'm
the little brother but i'm the bigger
brother
my youngest brother's taller than me and
he reminds me all the time
um all right so with trace
the whole idea here i mean it's like a
no-brainer high
uh idea of just like hey we should make
this more real-time we should have more
like
almost like streaming information right
if we have people who are making
decisions in forecasts and they don't
have information then they can't be
effective with it if we can then build
software to get them the information
faster into more real time they should
be more effective more efficient all
that kind of stuff absolutely okay great
makes sense
how do you build the product because
part of this i think is like most people
are
especially those that haven't built sas
software
or i guess you know software as a
service uh they're just not used to
building
for these big enterprises right they're
they're used to thinking about like
let's build a mobile app let's build a
website you know something that it's
more consumer-facing
what changes in the product development
cycle for you as you guys look to
service you know really big customers
that could pay you a lot of money
but also there could be five different
types of customers within one single
you know uh customer base right right
right right uh yeah it is tough
it's a balance i think you need to start
with like your insights or the problem
that you that you want to solve
and i think we were very clear around
kind of like yeah the insights and the
trends that we wanted to tackle with
initially thinking through the scope of
what we wanted to build
um you know i knew that we were it was i
wanted to do something in the finance
space and solve these specific problems
around
just collaborating with the business and
collecting this information and just
automating all these routine fpa tasks
so i've been there i've done it i've
been in the seat and so i think we
we kind of know you know
where we can provide value and really
where we can differentiate from other
players in the market
uh and then it's it's just like
tactically okay let's
you know now we have like a big vision
you know and we think
there's a huge category to be defined
here and to be captured here
how do we tactically go do that with
like you know a few million bucks of a
seed round and like you know a
you know handful of engineers and that's
where it gets a little bit more
difficult to say okay where do we start
what's our entry point with customers
and you know how do we how do we
navigate from there to then continue to
unlock and build
towards the vision and so that is a
process of just talking with customers
understanding their needs defining
requirements
and when you're building for the
enterprise there's not a lot of
shortcuts that you can take you know
especially when you're dealing with
financial software uh the security of
that information the security that data
working with the legacy like accounting
systems that you have to integrate with
to get data
all of those are kind of just table
stakes you know you have to do that you
have to do that
really well and increasingly with things
like security
you know you have to be like sock to
compliant and you need to make sure that
you're protecting people's data
and so that's core infrastructure that
we built in uh from the early days so
compared to like building a consumer
company where you're just like
you're just throwing ideas out there and
you're just trying to find a lightning
strike you know
with when you're building an enterprise
company you have to be really thoughtful
about how you architect the system and
you know how you sequence things to
deliver value to customers
i'm really fortunate to be working with
an incredible co-founder and cto
his name is martin destanio he sold his
last company to box led product and
engineering teams there for four years
uh serial entrepreneur so i think he
just understands how to build
but coming from box he understands you
know the importance of synchronization
you know and
you know box makes sure all your files
are synchronized
there's somebody coughing in the room
this is not allowed when we're in person
there's no coughing allowed all right
keep going sorry
leave that in don't edit that out
yeah so box you know he makes sure that
everything was synchronized you know
and it's the same thing when you're
dealing with financial data across
systems you need to make sure everything
is sync
and you also need to make sure that
those documents are secure you know and
box handles you know
government documents for government
agencies and so that security aspect
really came into play as well
and so we were really able to think
about you know things like
you know users and permissions what
users have
access to what pieces of the different
product what can they see what can they
not see
into the foundation early and that's
really going to be helpful
as we continue to scale and service
these bigger customers because we built
the infrastructure
anticipating okay we want to go serve
big enterprises you know down the road
and so that's good that we have that
infrastructure when you think about
what this will empower right so the
software we're just gonna
say it works we know the customers are
using it
how does it change a business right like
what is the outcome once they use it in
terms of
uh somebody buys into the vision they
say yes i want the real-time
information does it lead to more revenue
does it lead to just better forecasting
does it cut costs like
how do you think about the impact on an
actual business uh that's a great
question
uh i'm gonna mike all i do is ask great
questions
yeah yeah that's fair
i'm excited for the questions at the end
talk about aliens and stuff
yeah so i think i'm going to start with
like a few different areas
of where we deliver and where we're
going to create change so first is just
from like a cultural perspective
um and i think like trace it empowers
people and empowers people across the
business to
hire who they need to hire personally
need to hire to manage their projects
and i think
i think finance is kind of shifting away
from this old guard of like
gatekeepers and you know people who just
say no and they're realizing the real
way to lead
and the real way to get results is by
empowering people and holding them
accountable
and allowing them just to execute and
move with speed and i think that's kind
of the first shift
that you know finance will create in a
business it allows finance to be a
collaborative
partner to the rest of the business and
an enabler of the rest of the business
to allow people to move with speed
the downstream impacts of that is now
we're giving all of our business
partners a way
to collaborate with us to give us
information to get us in their minds of
like what are you thinking about doing
and all that information can then go be
used to just
supercharge existing financial systems
and finance teams and so it starts with
you know giving that real time forecast
to finance which is like an insight that
finance teams really
haven't had before you know they're
really in the dark without getting this
information
or if they want to go try to create this
in the old world it you know takes weeks
you know and at that point it's
it's already too late i mean this sounds
ridiculous and i can say this you can't
but like it's basically dinosaur
type approach to doing this right where
it's like very static
it's a kind of top-down centrally
planned
uh type environment to what you're
talking about is basically where the
world's going
right it's just real-time information
that now i say okay we thought x was
going to happen x didn't happen y
happened if we take that input and we
change it
rather than wait till the end of the
quarter to make any change we should
probably change it on day three of the
quarter so that the rest of the quarter
isn't screwed up
because one of the inputs we made into
the model is wrong absolutely absolutely
that's like a no-brainer like actually
coming from somebody
not from the finance department these
big organizations you're like well you
guys haven't been doing that yeah right
like like it's kind of crazy to think
about just
how um how hard it must be to do this
job
without real-time information right
right right absolutely
um one of the pieces of the software
that's really fascinating to me and i
actually i should have said in the
beginning i'm an investor
uh mike was nice he he's gonna try to
make us all rich so
he'll be much more richer than i am but
that's fine uh uh
is collaboration in terms of uh
you guys start out collaboration
pre-pandemic
so everyone's in the same office for the
most part right and we're using software
to help everyone kind of
work together better yep pandemic
happens people literally scatter all
over the world it's like collaboration
and collaboration software's more
important than ever
talk a little bit about just like what
this does to the internal communications
of teams
as they start to use the software yeah i
think well the first
thing is you know kind of when the
pandemic hit every single finance team
was put on tilt you know and then they
were saying okay like
what if we have to cut expenses by 20 25
what do we need to do you know and so
using a tool like trace to have the
visibility into
what's committed what's not committed
when are renewals when can we get out of
this contract you know when is this
contract end
those are some of the questions that we
allow people to answer so they can just
sleep easy you know at night you know
knowing that they have all this
information and they don't have to go
dig
through google drive or box folders
analyzing specific contracts trying to
enter information out
so we could have helped people really
get started and then from there
executing on new financial plans
at that time as people were kind of just
trying to figure out the new world they
were just like okay iterating you know
scenario one scenario two scenario three
and then when you pick a scenario need
to go you know execute that scenario you
need to okay
socialize that and then collaborate with
people
and collaborating on financial decisions
and information
is really really difficult thing to do i
mean i think there's just like a ton of
you know information there's a ton of
documents that needs to be
you know you need to have like both
tools that allow you to collect this
information to collect these documents
but chatting then in slack without the
context of this information
is really difficult a really difficult
thing to do you know and you know even
if it's just like for example if i want
to talk about a number in my financial i
might say
it's at the intersection of this
department this account you know this
location and this
and this date you know just so we can
make sure that we're talking about that
same piece of
data or information and so trace allows
people to
you know have productivity tools to get
their jobs done
but then also collaborate with that
information right there you know so if i
want to ping somebody and say hey
we got this renewal coming up like
should we renegotiate should we go look
for new vendors
do we want to cancel this all that can
happen in the product
and having that collaboration in context
is is really really helpful especially
when you can't just go knock on
somebody's desk and be like hey
i need your help you know we want to
make this change like is it good to go
uh and so i think it's it's it's
increasingly important to have good
productivity tools with collaboration
deeply ingrained
into the experience uh while we're
working remote
it almost feels like right now you guys
are taking the data you're saying hey
we're gonna
help you do you know more with this data
in terms of real time and
streaming and all that yeah and two it's
like hey we're going to help you
communicate and collaborate around the
data
and then eventually if you can basically
kind of almost like sync your hooks into
an organization right to some degree of
okay now we've got the data
and we've got you collaborating here you
can build all kinds of products in a
product suite that just
continue to solve problems for these
finance teams
and in some way it feels like maybe
there's been more software built for the
consumer like finance right whether it's
uh
taxes or you know p l's and stuff like
that
than it is for these like kind of growth
stage um
you know technology companies and if you
can really just essentially establish
that entire category
and be the product leader there then
it's a no-brainer right
yeah absolutely that's why i invested so
[Laughter]
yeah we think there is a new category
here you know i think there's like
categories of financial planning systems
there's categories of accounting systems
and i think that there's we think that
there's this new category that's based
around collaboration and workflows and
analytics
and does it have a name do you guys have
a name for it we call the category
finance service management
and service is a very key part of that
category name because we think about the
portfolio of services that finance needs
to offer the business
the problem with the incumbent systems
like the planning systems or the
accounting systems is they're really
built for finance they're not
built for the people in the business to
collaborate with those tools and to use
those and to use those tools
so the tool the current tools are built
specifically for finance teams to do
finance activities however these are
tools for finance yeah exactly what you
guys are saying is no
we need to give tools to the finance
teams that help them work better with
the product team or with the customer
service team
or whatever else this is not providing
connectivity between the finance team
and the rest of the organization
absolutely absolutely
we say that it's myself as even better
business than i thought damn
all right we don't actually compare a
category to uh you know existing
financial categories we say it's most
analogous to it service management so it
service management and finance service
management
i.t service management is companies like
servicenow and atlassian
and they built incredibly valuable
businesses around a really simple
concept of a ticket you know you need
anything from it
you go create that ticket it was kind of
like the core
of you know what those systems started
as and that doesn't really exist in
finance
and interestingly a lot of people use
atlassian's jira product for some of
these workflows you know where it's like
i need a workflow ticketing system for
purchase requests or hiring requests and
so they end up using generic workflows
but they're not built for it you're not
built to understand your financial data
you know to do all of the connections
with your financial systems and give you
all the outputs that trace is going to
be doing
um but so from an from like a from an
analogy perspective we're most similar
to those businesses and i mean
you know servicenow's 100 billion dollar
business atlassian 50 billion dollar
business two of the top ten
enterprise cloud software companies um
so we think there's huge category upside
to the to the to finance service
management
all right so you've raised a good amount
of money for early stage technology
company
uh walk through what that experience has
been like and kind of what are some of
the tips and tricks that you picked up
as you went through the fundraising
process
so if there's a founder out there who's
like hey i'm about to go raise capital
like what are the things that you found
that worked for you
um i think that's a great it's a great
question i told you only great questions
uh i think people say that's a great
question when they're trying to like buy
themselves some time
i know i'm not gonna call anybody on it
i've called people out on it before but
go ahead
yeah uh we were fortunate to have a
great early investor jeff claviate on
court capital
um he calls he's you know the og of seed
investing he's been doing it for a
really
a really long time um it wasn't early it
wasn't easy for us you know
to get started on the kind of the
fundraising trail and so first piece of
advice is
i think people give this advice all the
time is test your pitch with friends
and like you know you know people who
you can really trust and dial that pitch
in before you go kind of talk to your
ideal you know investors um so it's
basically start with the people who not
necessarily you don't want
but start with people who either aren't
actually investors but can give you
feedback
they may be uh people in the industry or
people that you trust and know
and then almost move in and go pitch the
people who like they're nice to haves
first
and then work your way up to the people
that actually you want i think that's a
good idea
i think and you'll you'll have a good
feeling when that pitch is kind of
dialed in and your story is really
dialed in
and it takes some time to kind of
iterate on on that uh i think we met
jeff
at a good time i think he was a believer
in the category believer in the
potential and really a believer
in the team and so we initially raised a
3 million
kind of seed financing and that allowed
us to go
build our early team develop these kind
of proof points
we brought in some institutional
investors into that round
and so we brought in red point greylock
and nika
all in about equal amounts and they're
typically a little bit later stage
investors and so i think there's always
a
question that an entrepreneur needs to
ask themselves it's
you know if you're going to bring in a
later stage investor that
brings signaling risk at the early
stages so if they invest early on they
decide not to do
subsequent financing that can be bad
signal to other investors in the market
at the same time you get their brand you
get their power behind you
early on and so we made the decision
that instead of bringing in like two big
institutional seeds encore capital is
just primarily a seed investor
you know and jeff will say his job is to
go you know help us get that series
series a done he's not going to lead the
lead the series i we made the decision
to bring on those
uh you know bigger investors and for us
it worked to be a great a great decision
uh we were we had are fortunate to be
working with sarah wow at greylock
she's been an incredible partner from
the very beginning i think
she's she deeply understands our market
and what we aspire to do i think she's a
true believer in the category and the
potential
uh and she's done the work to speak with
cfos in her network
you know they introduce us to customers
that we can go chat with even early on
before we were at the stage of our
product being ready to sell
you know she would sit in on the demos
and actually do the work you know and
you know it's it's
it's rare to have a partner that's gonna
like you know of course open up the
rolodex
introduce you to folks but then actually
go and sit in the meeting and see how it
goes and get that feedback you know so
even in the early days when we're still
developing our product
you know you can see how you know
finance people respond to it like kind
of like your response like
yes we need this it's like why has this
not been done before you know and you
can you can develop that conviction over
time
and so then when we see opportunities to
raise more money move faster you know we
want to increase and accelerate on the
pro
on the product roadmap we've had
supportive investors and greylock has
continued to invest
in us which is which has been fast it's
been allowed us to you know hire our
first founding lead designer
we're currently hiring for engineers so
if you're an engineer looking for a job
come talk to trace or go to go to pomp's
crypto jobs
depending on depending on what what what
type of you know sector industry you
want to work in
wait wait hold on before all right so if
you're an engineer you should talk to
trace
i'm super impressed by sarah going to
the actual meetings yes
she's that's incredible yeah she's uh
she's a great she's a great partner
she's when her and i meet i
i i say i enjoy the meetings because i
always learn something
and that's of course you know you love
to chat with people that you always get
to learn learn stuff from and you can
actually
have a good sparring partner when they
understand and they've done the homework
uh so i think it's pretty i think it's
pretty rare to have found that any other
investors or advisors that have like
stuck out in terms of
uh either over delivering or like you're
like hey look like they're super
valuable that uh doing something that
people
normally wouldn't do yeah a couple
people come to mind i mean you're you're
you're the one
you can't come you're the first person
that come to mind because i mean i think
yeah i think we were fortunate to have
you and i think you came in it's not
like
you know you write you write big checks
for big companies you do big deals and
big rounds
yeah big deal
[Laughter]
man i'm gonna cut that that's gonna go
somewhere i don't know where we're gonna
put that but that was a great
[ __ ] clip but the beauty of it is
like you know you have a small check in
trace but every single time and
obviously we're friends so it's a little
bit different but every single time i
call you it's like
you know i have somebody that i can get
feedback from good good feedback so i
always appreciated that um somebody else
who comes to mind
a couple people come to mind um uh
charlie kievers he's the cfo at carta
he's an investor in us um and you know
it was in our early deal we didn't have
a lot of allocation to share so it's not
like a
a big check um but always supportive i
mean whenever we want to meet he gives
us his time whenever we have resources
like he shares resources he's always
willing to make introductions
uh and there's a handful of people like
like that that are just like
the true believers uh and yes so so
fortunate for
for all of them i can i can go on and on
what's fascinating to me is just
the common thread through a lot of that
i think it's like time right
and and if you think about it from uh um
all these kind of solo capitalists or
people who are writing angel
checks etc uh we've got a couple of
companies that i've put you know pretty
big checks into
and then there's like 20 checks that are
literally like a thousand bucks 2500
bucks 5
000 bucks whatever um and now founders
are starting to use like angels has a
new product where basically you can kind
of pull
a bunch of really small checks it's one
line item on your cap table
so maybe you want people with big
audience or people who are an expert in
a specific space or whatever
and uh what's fascinating to me is if
you go talk to the founders so like oh
those people are way more helpful
right like you know maybe i've got like
one big investor who's really helpful or
has opened up the rolodex kind of like
what sarah it sounds like has done for
you and and jeff as well
uh but then there's like oh this person
who's like actually really really
valuable to me
doesn't even have that big of an
economic stake but like they're always
there i know i can call them whatever
and to me i think that's the argument
for like why people should do more angel
investing
right is because you forget that uh that
person is actually getting value out of
it as well
right like there's probably very few
people who wrote a small check who are
like oh it's gonna be life-changing
it's more so they're either learning
they enjoy it they want to help people
like like there's some other
non-economic benefit to them for doing
it yeah and so it's fascinating to hear
that like
the time investment the the access is is
almost more important than the money
right yeah
absolutely i think there's a rise of the
operator investor right now and i think
increasingly we're seeing
a lot of great operators who are you
know c level vp level
starting to write checks um and and i
think entrepreneurs are learning that
those are some of the best people to
have on your
cap table in our most recent financing
we brought in a syndicate from fog
ventures
it's operators guild is the network and
it's like 500
you know operators who are vp ceo cfo
type folks
and we were able to bring together a
great syndicate uh of i think we have
like
40 different you know vp cfo level folks
um and you know i think it's early in
terms of like our relationship with them
but we're already getting
so much from them and so much from that
network i think increasingly
entrepreneurs are going to want
those types of folks on their cap tables
who can really really help
for sure all right before i let you go i
want to talk about investing in general
uh have you done anything in crypto
i have i've i own yeah encrypted on
bitcoin all right
well i mean okay let's go back let's go
back to yeah
time at facebook i think it was like
what 2014.
we were i know this you weren't like
huge into crypto at the time
um but you you we were talking about it
we were on the shuttle you know there's
probably a giants game so we're like
sitting waiting
45 minutes just sitting on the shuttle
trying to pass time
uh and we were talking about buying
crypto and buying bitcoin and i'm i
started doing
my homework you know and then one day
i'm like okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna
you know buy some just tiny at location
uh so we're on the shuttle i got my
wi-fi going i
go to coinbase and i'm like filling it
out and then they
they asked me for my license and i'm
just like all right that's where things
start you know
now you don't need that you don't put my
license on this website yeah
and so looking back that was a little
bit a little bit of a bummer i wish i
would have done that but i think
i've gotten it honestly i think your
conviction in it and your conviction
along the way
is like i've done my research and like
i've come to believe that like
you know this should be an allocation uh
in anybody's portfolio and i'm not
i'm not you know i'm more of uh you're
not a 95
guy i stick to my finance principles
but at the same time it's like let your
winners ride you know yeah you know when
you were debating with jason uh
calcaneus about this it's like well
jason calcane's got a fiat haircut i
love jason to death but he's got a fiat
haircut
just so we're all clear for anyone who's
been watching this podcast or watching
andrew schultz podcast
jason is the one who started the fiat
haircut whole situation i love you jason
you didn't see me in miami so you're
gonna get that right there on the chin
but
i still love you uh that's the whole
thing go ahead
yeah i mean let your winners ride you
know and i think that's something that
he believes and so if if
you know uber ends up becoming 95
percent of your portfolio i mean like
you you got to
you got to let your winners ride what
else are you invested in
like that dollar amounts but just like
from a percentage basis just ballpark
is it mostly equities is it like others
like how do you think about
in today's world uh creating a portfolio
like like how do you think through that
i think you need it depends on your time
horizon it depends on your risk profile
i'm you know a big believer in the
enterprise software
asset class and i think you know of
course i'm building trace and so a lot
of my eggs
are in the trace basket but i really
believe in just the opportunity
in just cloud cloud software and i think
what we've seen is like
in that in that asset class i mean we
can talk about
you know bitcoin now being a trillion
dollars the enterprise
enterprise cloud or cloud you know asset
classes a two trillion dollar asset
class and the top five companies
in that top five are a trillion dollars
so you can compare those top five
to you know to bitcoin uh and see like
how do those two things stack up
i would say that it makes sense for
people to have good exposure to
the cloud the cloud category and when
you when you look at the cloud
it was you know roughly 600 billion a
couple years ago you know and now it's
two trillion
it's coming back a little bit as
interest rates are going up and
multiples contract a bit
but i think there's still just so much
upside and i think you're seeing that
in in the markets you know and i think
you're seeing some of these public guys
come downstream and get deeper and
deeper you know and go more and more
upstream and that capital is kind of
continuing to flood up into
into startups and i think there's just a
huge opportunity and
those numbers i just gave were for
publicly traded companies when you think
when you look at private
unicorns companies valued over a billion
dollars
that represents there's like over five
500 unicorn
yeah unicorns and that represents
another two trillion in
uh in value as well so just four
trillion total
really big numbers yeah and those are
for unicorns so there's even more at the
earlier stages
uh and you we talk about asymmetric bets
and how bitcoin was you know
one of the one of if not the greatest
asymmetric bet
you know of all time i think you're
still seeing that in
early stage businesses in the cloud
software cloud software category yeah
i mean i talk about all the time right
like uh from a professional standpoint
a little bit different personally but
professionally uh
when i think about allocating capital
if you invested in coinbase's seed round
or series a or bought bitcoin on the
same day
coinbase's equity actually outperformed
bitcoin right now maybe
at some point in the future that doesn't
end up being true forever or whatever
but like up until now that's true
yeah there's a lot of businesses that
are very similar to that right block fi
gemini
kraken like all these different
companies and so i think that
uh it's less about like equity versus
like
crypto assets right or these liquid
tokens and it's more so about like
sector bets
right and if you think about it probably
the two best sectors in the world to
have bet on over the last
five years it's like cloud software and
crypto yeah
right and maybe there's one or two
others you could throw in there but like
those are basically the
future right in terms of the way that
people are going to get software
delivered they're going to pay for it et
cetera and all the cloud stuff
yep and then two is like this whole
reworking of a financial system
yeah like outside of those two things
you'd be hard-pressed to find two other
sectors
that you'd want to go bet so heavily on
so i think it's more
it's less about like uh they're
competitive and it's more so just like
i don't know there'll be like five
sectors that you know in hindsight
people looking back oh if you were along
those sectors you could have been an
idiot and make money absolutely right
and like cloud software's definitely one
of the five absolutely
yeah just go long technology
i mean uh we we could talk about warren
buffett and charlie munger's
recent comments because i think both you
and i uh respect them very deeply like
from uh
uh just this historic run but like they
don't understand technology at all
right right and like it's pretty crazy
to uh
hear the like flippant conversations and
uh um and the responses to like all
these questions
and to me it's like very weird because
uh
i think we know that like athletes are a
great example right athletes like
go through this process of they get
better they improve they get better at
some point they peak
if they're a professional athlete
hopefully it's when they're a
professional and then there's kind of
this like decline
and if you're really really good like
maybe a tom brady who you know he's owen
to in the super bowl against eli manning
he's been able to stay around for a
really long time he plays into his 40s
right and like
that peaking where did he peek did he
already peak is he
got the future to pete like nobody knows
but eventually like he'll decline he'll
have to retire
yeah uh in business you obviously have a
lot more longevity right
but like at some point like yeah there
is a decline yeah and so
is it 60s 70s 80s
like by 90 you've probably
you know on the way down which again
doesn't take away like if you were so
much better than everybody else like
you could have declined 50 percent of
your skills and evaluations
uh abilities etc and still be better
than everybody right right
but it just feels like there's an entire
generation of people who like completely
miss cloud they completely miss crypto
and i still think through is it an age
and like a demographic thing
is it a just experience thing like if
you don't grow up with a super phone in
your
hand do you actually end up just not
understanding the importance of cloud
computing i i don't know but it feels
like
even when you listen to earnings calls
and stuff like there's a lot of people
who still
are like i don't know and you're like
dude what like you don't believe in
cloud computing or like that's not like
a material thing for you
moving forward and so yeah i mean you
know this stuff better than i but it
just seems kind of crazy that there's
still people who
uh maybe they don't not believe but they
just are uh
less convinced that that should be like
a big part of their portfolio
yeah it is interesting and i think
there's like some strategy aspects to
this as well where it's like
all i want to do is compound my money at
like eight percent you know
and if i mean eight percent damn all
right we gonna have to
talk about this crypto stuff when we get
done eight percent bitcoins goes up and
down eight percent in a day
yeah well i'm talking about some of
these old school you know money managers
where it's like
oh okay yeah if i'm at eight percent i'm
doing my job you know and i only want to
take on enough risk i don't want to take
on you know any risk i just want to
compound at eight percent
and i will do that for the next century
you know and i think
and that's it's a smart way to play it
right because if you just look at
compounding and being in the market
uh you know i think this is the stuff
that we need to start teaching our kids
it's like
the basics of you know compounding and
financial literacy
but those mental models around how you
can get that eight percent and what that
looks like
is changing you know and amazon is the
prime example is how many people missed
amazon because amazon wasn't generating
cash
and and you know amazon was just piling
cash into
new knew it just driving it investing it
right back into the business
and that's the same thing with a lot of
these cloud
cloud software businesses that are you
know running on subscriptions and ar arr
models where they're not getting
every single piece of cash up front and
i think these businesses have to
they're investing a dollar because
they're going to get three dollars you
know over some
over some time horizon and so early on
these businesses are like oh they're not
generating cash or they're not
generating earnings
but if you understand how the model
works from a subscription and this like
lifetime value of every single customer
that you get
has a lifetime value assigned to it you
know and so i will invest
a dollar you know if my lifetime value
is going to give me three dollars over
time
and it takes time for that to play out
and i think now that people are starting
to see
that you know these businesses actually
can't print cash
it was hard to see that early on and so
i think you know
um berkshire has invested you know in
you know some of the high-flying
companies now i think snowflake they
were they were in and i think snowflake
trades at the
highest multiple like in enterprise
software right now so i think that one's
probably like warren's probably sweating
he's like i i know he didn't make that
decision somebody on his team did but
it's cool to see them finally starting
to understand like
how these business models work and how
they can print cash over time
the top five enterprise or top five
cloud software
businesses are gonna do 100 billion in
revenue next year they're going to print
20 billion
in cash and so these businesses can just
you know
once the machine is working and at scale
deliver incredible returns for investors
and i think that's why investors assign
you know i think the cl the category
trades at 20 x you know revenue and i
think it's because people can anticipate
what those revenue streams
and that growth will will look like into
the future with with a relative
high degree of accuracy um so yeah
investors love those businesses
and it feels like uh they're really
sticky too
right like once somebody starts using
the software i mean you really gotta
screw up
to uh to get somebody to leave and so
when you start looking at the retention
uh it's like whoa this is not only a
great business to begin with it's also
then you got the customer for
you know years what better business than
that right
absolutely absolutely and like a lot of
these businesses it's not just retention
where it's like
we kept every single customer we got 100
retention a lot of time those contracts
will increase
you know and so then you can say my
dollar retention if this was a
this is a 10 contract this year it's 130
contract now my retention rate is 130
and when you start modeling that out
where my customer base as a whole is
going to be you know say its dollar
retention 120
130 now you're getting a compounding
rate on just your existing revenue base
not to mention what you're bringing in
net new
and so that you know is a compounding
factor you of course you can discount it
but you know once you start getting into
modeling what these businesses will look
like with that high retention rate
you know you're not even looking at
maybe an annuity stream that it looks
like with some you know
end in sight now it's looking like a
perpetuity of the way you model it and
you discount it
um and so there's just so much value to
extract from when those business models
are working
and the software to your point is
incredibly sticky you know a system like
trace
integrates with your accounting system
all your all the people in the business
are using it
they're not getting rid of you once
you're in they're not getting rid of you
but
it's not because you like came up with
some trick it's because it actually
works it provides value
we solve problems we deliver value
absolutely they they need to use the
software in order to run their business
better
which is like the crazy thing is uh how
do you build a great business just solve
people's problems absolutely
yeah right yep all right i could talk to
you all day
uh uh my notes i didn't use them one
time so i'm going back to no
notes [ __ ] the notes um three questions
one what's the most important book
you've ever read
most important book i ever read
i would say the the most important book
to me right now is called survival to
thrival
how to build an enterprise how to build
an enterprise startup all right um
and survival to what survival to thrival
thrival
yeah and it's a book that was a word
survival to thrival
yeah and
it was a book written by entrepreneurs
who built
you know cloud software enterprise
software uh and it's been awesome for
the journey and i
we give it to every single employee who
starts at trace
because it start talks about the early
stages of founding finding product
market fit
finding go to market fit you know and i
can say as we've been on this journey
with trace
i felt like i'd be like okay we're on
page 38 we're going to page 39
you know and it's really nice to you
know that people have been like
sharing this information um and so for
anybody who's out there that's like
thinking about starting a business
uh you know you can do it you know have
the courage
you know there's so much information out
there there's no limiting beliefs it's
like you can go do whatever you want
uh facts facts it's probably the thing
that you and i agree on the most out of
anything in the world
is like there's an entire group of
people who literally think the world's
like
i don't know conspiring against them
yeah and then there's a group of people
who are just like dude i'm going to go
do what i want to do because i can
yeah right and it's like if i want to be
a
you know successful entrepreneur i can
go do that if i want to learn investing
i can go do that if i literally want to
go be a piano player like i can go
figure out how to do that
but it's this like self-starter
mentality right and this like uh
um as i'm fond of tweeting like no one's
coming to save you like
like it is on you and i think that
that's kind of the way that you guys
have built
trace and and really just live your life
right 100
and if there's one thing that i can that
i aspire to do
as i you know build trace and have more
success is for
like kids who grew up in you know rough
areas or rough neighborhoods you know
like like we did who
they don't know these things right and
they think that like their world is
constrained to this box
and it's only this box that they know
there is literally
no box there is you have the internet no
constraints
like you can literally go do what do
what you want you know and just dream
big aspire big and just work
you know work relentlessly and don't
stop
sleep schedule eat sleep uh
for those that don't know i've been
asking this question for eight sleep for
a while now i'm an investor in the
company because literally it changed my
life
uh my brother and i have a competition
as to who can sell more eight sleeps
uh he beat me last month for the first
time ever which is crazy i think that he
conspired with mateo the ceo
i know that you're really into health
and fitness uh just look at him he
literally works out every day i can
still beat him at basketball though
back so let's talk about sleep i have a
question i have a question
this is gonna be a great question what's
the worst you've been beat in a game of
one-on-one basketball
i don't think i've ever lost i can't
think of a single time i've ever lost a
game in basketball
if it happened i don't remember it why
go ahead tell your story
we were playing with so 4 30 a.m shuttle
we get to facebook 5 36
something like that and i think we
decided not to lift that day
all right we go play basketball or play
one-on-one i think you beat me the first
game
and i think we ended up well i should
have stopped there that sounds like the
lesson of this story because i think it
was like okay so then i won like the
next two i think was like our fourth
game that we're playing we're playing
games to eleven ones and twos yep
and i just got on like the hottest hot
shots
i'm not gonna admit i remember it but i
remember it i was banking in
threes from like from the not even from
half court like i think he was on the
other end of the court and he was
literally like throwing it underhand it
was just going in i was like this is
absurd i think i made six straight shots
and it was just like 11-0 game over
that that didn't happen i i hate to
admit it but that did happen that's
actually the only time i remember losing
the other two that you said i don't
remember this yeah
it's funny because if like that happened
with me and matt my brother
he would just like it would just be
completely out of his mind he would not
not ever remember like mike
mike isn't even good at basketball i
literally beat mike every time i play
him
all right sleep schedule what uh what
was it like and then how has that
changed over the pandemic
i used to be a yeah i used to be a
you know sleep sleep when i die guy you
know like let me sleep like five hours a
night and
especially when i was like you know at
zenefits and i was
really dialed in into just career
success and making an impact
um and then i think i've always just
been
big into studying and research
especially like around my body working
out like what feels good
uh and i've really come around to the
idea of just you need to get you need to
get more sleep uh
and so i would love to get eight hours
every night uh i'm
i'm a big believer in whoop and i think
the whoopi man i've been using it for
two years yeah
i wish i was an investor what does it
tell you that like you actively use
because i i think like whoop apple watch
like they all tell a kind of different
metrics what's the thing like when you
wake up and you look at the metrics like
what's the thing you look at
uh so i look at when i wake up i look at
sleep it's like literally the first
thing i do okay i
like how many hours i got how many hours
of sleep that i got it gives you a
recovery score so it looks at your heart
rate variability and i think eight sleep
tracks heart rate variability uh as well
i didn't know what this was until like a
year ago and
hrv is like the most important thing
that all these people tell me they look
at
yeah yeah yeah and so yeah whoop gives
that to you in a score
so then it tells you like okay you
worked out this hard yesterday
here's what your sleep recovery was and
so you know here's your recovery rate
and you want to be like yellow green
you don't want to be in in the red and
so i look at that i look at my resting
heart rate
um and i think what are you putting up
resting heart rate
i'm like in the high 30s um what i'm
somewhere like around
what my resting heart rate is like
recently it's been around 38 to 40.
interesting bro are you alive 38 to 40
years you're resting heart rate i
thought mine was
i'm at 50. yeah matt matt my brother
he's at he's at 35. which is like does
his heart not work which is like lance
armstrong type you know
wait 38 to 40 is your resting heart rate
yep
dang man i was flexing on people with 50
because my brother's at 53 and i was
like joe you're not
even that healthy 38 to 40. you should
get a whoop
yeah maybe maybe it's the apple watch it
is bad data all right
that must be what it is i gotta get a
whoop and then i'll have 38. it's fun
because like actually i have 37. yeah
by that time i'll be at 35.
but what i love about it is like you can
have a team you know and
so it's like me my brother and my dad's
in it you know and so like every single
day look at everybody's we can see
activity like how hard you worked out
you know you can see you can see your
recovery you can see your hours of sleep
um and so yeah it's great i also look at
like calories burned and so every single
day it's like okay how many calories did
i burn how many calories can i assume
and so then you can kind of play around
with it you know in terms of like do i
want to you know gain or do i want to
lose a little bit of weight so it's
awesome to have this level of insight
you know
one of the first times i remember going
to the gym with you uh i was in san
francisco then went to a crunch gym
shout out crunch uh and i think that we
went there
i'm pretty sure that we were trying to
see who could bench more uh
but towards like the middle of the
workout i was like you want to go for a
run i know you just let me go
i don't run i remember okay
they're like damn all right and then
you're like the most cardio i do is i go
on the stair stepper thing like the you
know the stairs that rotate and i
remember being like
damn man he he's in a different world
but you had you always had that football
player strength you know like i would be
doing workouts and we put 225 you know
and
like we would we'd go for 12 or
something like that you know and then
you would you know you would probably
like start dying down you know you'd do
like eight
and then we'd keep going up and then
we'd be at like 3 15 or 3 35
and i'm like done i'm gassed and you're
just like i'm like what the hell
where did that come from just wondering
where did that come from
yeah i mean you know it's you ain't got
when you gotta do it 12 times like if
you're like if your life matters
you just gotta do it once you know just
push somebody away whatever
just i'm not into doing it a bunch of
times just you know just say yeah i
could do that one time
my my brothers give me a hard time
because uh they're all weaker every
single one of my brothers is weaker than
me just put that on the record
uh but when we go to the gym
they're like dude you were going to the
gym and you work out for 25 minutes
i'm like yeah i don't have time to be
like sitting around playing they've like
got music they do this
i'm just like in and out and so uh
literally now the joke is like when we
go the second we walk in like you done
already
yeah whatever all right third question
you get asked me one is uh aliens are
you a believer
i am uh oh my god don't tell me no
i am i'm like i don't i'm not informed
but i see enough
where i just don't know you know and i'm
not gonna do the homework to like figure
out
if they're if there's aliens or not you
know um
do you like that there's a higher
probability or lower probability i think
that there's probably something out
there there's probably aliens out there
and i think like yeah i think it depends
on your definition of alien yeah right
it's like
there's probably not a little green men
but it's probably like life
whatever yeah if aliens if aliens
were real and they did come like we
would probably be friends with them
yeah i mean i i tell polina all the time
that like she's like what would you do
if an alien should i like go to the bar
and get a beer
what's up man you want to go back to my
country
sure i think it's on another planet
though uh
would you rather go spend a year on the
international space station go
underneath the water
to the depths of the ocean for a year or
go to mars and not be able to come back
if you're gonna pick one of the three
it's my new this is my new
thing to ask people i'm picking none of
the above
i would like to stay in my condo with my
laptop
[Laughter]
i'm more scared of the ocean than i am
of space uh
why do you say that i guess like if in
either situation if anything happens
like you're dead
yeah but like there's just something
about like being underwater at the
depths of the ocean
and being like yo i can't get out like i
don't know it just freaks me out like
space kind of feels like you know we're
floating out here chilling yeah
yeah would you uh would you would you go
to space
if i could come back but like i asked
my youngest brother john the other day i
said hey if would you go to mars if you
couldn't come back and
he actually had a great response he goes
well what's there like am i going to
hang out people am i going alone
right so it's kind of like uh if you
knew that it was like a better place
like what if i told you mars was better
than earth then okay like maybe right
let's go check it out
yeah well i'm not gonna go first uh i do
appreciate though that everyone got mad
at elon musk because he said he was
going to create the laws on mars yeah
and uh he was like they were asking him
like what are the laws going to be like
we'll figure it out when we get there
and they're like you can't do that and
he was like okay well you go and figure
it out then
and everyone gets real quiet right so
it's like uh we just don't know yeah
like i think that's what's so much fun
to talk about right it's like
how long would it take to get there you
read they're like oh they created oxygen
on mars like
wait what like okay they're like oh we
found this like ice
well that sounds like we got oxygen in
water so like that sounds like we might
really pull this thing off and it's like
in 50 years
are there any people on mars like
probably probably
they just flew a helicopter right like
sure and it was a little
you know robotic one with it but like
dude imagine 20 years ago telling people
we're gonna fly a helicopter on mars
they'd be like you guys are crazy
yeah i i still got some exploring in
miami to do so i'm good
there's enough city here for me to go
explore
you could ask me one question what do
you have um
well i guess first i would say that like
um
i think this is awesome i think the
platform that you built is awesome i
think it's awesome to see you on cnbc
as somebody who's known you for a while
like seeing you on cnbc i'm like man
that is awesome
like that is super cool it's pretty
ridiculous yeah as a friend i'm
happy for you i'm proud of you um i
think what was interesting to see
is like you've been such a believer in
this for so long uh and to see like when
bitcoin crashed
like three 4k and like held your
conviction held your belief
uh and knowing some people who are like
not maybe not friends but acquaintances
like
attack you on twitter call your grifter
like all this stuff like i don't think
people understand like
how disciplined you are how hard you
work and like
you know that like this is not just some
like overnight success it's actually
years you know decades of like hard work
and dedication
uh and so what would you say to the
haters
[Laughter]
other than buy bitcoin what what do you
want to tell those folks now that we've
like 15 to 20 acts from that from that
law
i mean to be honest like
i just kind of feel bad like people
always ask me like what's the most fun
part about bitcoin and like look the
memes are
awesome uh the dancing on graves on the
internet is hysterical
right like i enjoy it just as much as
anybody no no the best the best meme is
this
is like the snoop dogg where you get the
hat and you get the little you get the
cigarette
that's literally the dog's life that's
through the [ __ ] life theme is literally
the best meme
when i saw that i'm like alright pops
made it i don't remember who made the
very first one
but when i saw that i literally was like
this i may put this on like a tv
on my my tombstone when i die just so
you guys all know
um no i i think that uh the part that i
enjoy the most about all of this
is uh i got a message uh the other day
actually hold on i'm going to read this
out because i don't want to mess it up
but i get these messages like this
probably on a
daily basis if not daily then i get them
for sure weekly
and this one specifically uh was
interesting
because hold on where
is this yeah i mean there's just so many
people out there who
uh probably just appreciate the
dedication to it
so this is a person who i don't want to
show so i'll just show you
but basically they've messaged me a lot
yep and
the last time they messaged me was back
in march uh and they were like joking
around all this stuff
yesterday at 7 18 a.m they said today is
my first day
of my retirement thank you pomp for
helping me see the light
best regards then they put their name
yeah
and i like get those messages and i have
no clue who this person is
uh literally it's a pseudonymous account
and i have no clue what they did to get
to this point so they could have been
55 60 70 years old right they put 10 000
it went up and then also now they've got
money they can retire
or they could be like literally like a
25 year old kid and you know whatever
but i think like what people forget is
there's like uh this day is a little old
there's probably at this point over a
hundred thousand wallets
that have more than a million dollars of
bitcoin in it wow
right i think i'm pretty sure that's
correct when you think about
what that does to like an entire
generation of people it's crazy
yeah and that's just bitcoin and you
look at all this other stuff
and so uh recently barry silbert uh from
digital currency group he tweeted out
and he was like
the amount of wealth creation is like
staggering in this industry
that's all great but who cares about
like the money
as much as like imagine being somebody
who wanted to retire couldn't
and then all of a sudden does something
they can retire so like that's all the
positive stuff that i enjoy when you
flip it around you look at like the
hater side
yeah i just always go back to like i
feel bad for them
like man you have such a shitty life
that you're literally on the internet
talking [ __ ] to somebody who you don't
know
right and then like the best part always
is like i'll dm them sometimes
and then they're super nice right like
immediately they're like oh i'm so nice
like whatever
and so it's just like uh when you look
at it almost like empathetically and
you're just like
man that's really you woke up this
morning and that is what you decided to
say on the internet yeah like
are you okay all right what you realize
is like one it's easy because it's like
super non-personal rights people can
attack people like all this kind of
stuff there's pseudonymity
and whatever yeah but then the second
thing is just like
if you meet them in person they would
never say that and by the way you would
never
like say anything back either and so
like i think that for all the benefits
of the internet there's downsides
uh and so if you ask me this question
two years ago
i said all kinds of crazy stuff like
really crazy stuff
um now i just kind of look at it and i'm
just like
man like you you can participate in this
just as much
and so i'll tell you uh one last story
before we go
i went to dinner recently uh plano was
there with me
i don't want to say who was there but
there was very successful people there
and one of the people was uh a hedge
fund
private equity person they had no clue
any of the bitcoin crypto
any stuff at one point during the dinner
they started to go on and on and on
all about uh the game stop
longs were manipulating the market and
screwing the hedge funds
i just sat there listened for a little
bit and plano was looking at me like
i know this dude ain't gonna sit here
and not say anything
and so at some point i just very
cordially was like yeah but like
aren't the hedge funds manipulating the
market as well with all of their
research and you know their comments and
going on television and like all this
stuff and everything yeah and his credit
he was like oh that's a good point
right like that's fair but i think
that's like what the internet's done
right is like the internet didn't
necessarily like
swing markets or do anything all day was
it created more accessibility
and then it allowed for everyone else to
do the same thing that the hedge funds
are doing
right or do or professional investors or
whatever and so to me like the people
who are mad about this
usually there was a guy literally today
who told me uh
i tweeted out and i was like if you're a
young person don't go work at a
traditional bank or traditional asset
manager like all of the innovation and
most of the returns moving forward is
going to be encrypted like go get a job
in crypto
of course this guy runs like a four
billion dollar hedge fund which by the
way if you're on a four billion dollar
hedge fund you're talking [ __ ] on the
internet like you should be doing way
better things or
your investors should take their money
back uh and so
he basically was like look uh this is
stupid advice if you get a job offer
from like goldman sachs or susquehanna
or any of these places like you should
go take it
and i was like hey man like you're
confusing like
take susquehanna for example they're not
a traditional asset manager like they're
one of the biggest players in crypto
so like sure go work but go work on
their crypto desk and he was like oh
uh trading equities at susquehanna is
better than any job you guys have
and like the response i want to say
frankly which i didn't i actually typed
it out and deleted it because it wasn't
worth my time
was like dude we can compare your hedge
fund returns to like
literally strangers on the internet who
just held bitcoin for last five years so
they destroyed you and you're charging
two and twenty
and they literally are better at your
job than you are right
and so like sure returns end up like
being the scoreboard
yep but at the end of the day like all
you're seeing is like it's fear
they're literally scared so if you're
trading public equities you're doing all
this stuff
you have a decision either you can adapt
or you will die like you
your business will be disrupted because
everything is going to move to the open
public blockchains
and so when i just think through that
i'm like all right so if somebody's
being
aggressive or like negative either
literally something's probably wrong
and like be empathetic or two like
they're fearful and like when they're
fearful like
hey man you see the same thing i do it's
just either you operate at a fear you
operate out of optimism and like
optimism always wins optimism always
wins yeah so like you know
whatever [ __ ] off
i mean you know at some point you just
throw your hands up and you're just like
whatever i'm gonna do my own thing
like not the time yeah knock yourselves
out whatever so uh
by the way if you're a young person you
go work at uh trading equity somewhere
then you probably should
have an intelligence test because that's
probably not the best thing to do so all
right man tracehq.com
tracehq.com where can people find you on
twitter
uh mike uh underscore underscore gods
two underscores all right it's tough to
get it tough to get a handle
yeah mike mike mike mike gonzalez is a
common name
do you want to tell a story real quick
uh no we'll save it for next time
all right thank you so much for doing
this thank you for having me it was fun